hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in chapters 16 17 and 18 of his treatise
on virtues and vices alcuin of york is
going to discuss
three important if not virtues
themselves certainly
actions or courses of action
that are expressive of virtue and that
play a role in combating
against three of the capital vices and
so these are fasting
alms giving and chastity and if you
think about it so fasting is opposing
the vice of gluttony
and chastity clearly opposing the vice
of lust or fornication
what is almsgiving opposing it's not a
corporeal
vice rather it's a spiritual one
it opposes greed
and so each of these is opposing one of
the first three
of the capital vices
and he says something very interesting
in chapter 17 about almsgiving he tells
us that almsgiving and fasting
have a particular connection
with prayer and intercession and this is
you know not just a typical medieval
christian point of view we can find this
in a number of other spiritual
traditions as well and he says
intercession for sins is most effectual
in alms giving and fastings and the
prayer raised up from such decisions
ascends quickly to divine ears
since it is written in here he's going
to cite proverbs a merciful man benefits
his soul and so there's a lot of
discussion in there about what is it
that doing these
physical things how do they affect our
spiritual condition
so if we look first at fasting
fasting is the
reduction or the
you know limitation or abstention
from eating and drinking and it could
apply to eating and drinking
just normal food we could also think
about you know abstaining from drinking
wine or other intoxicants
the latin word for it is union
and so this chapter is about that and he
says that and there's a very very
important point
it is perfected
by alms in prayer
so just like with these others
just by themselves they're not as
effective they're not as
perfect in the sense of brought to their
their fulfillment they're not doing
their
function this is not about like dieting
it's not just about you know
subordinating the body to the mind and
being you know harsh with yourself it's
supposed to be helping you out as a
human being to go in the
right way
and so he says that
through it a human is made spiritual
is joined with the angels and united
freely with god that joined with the
angels is also something he's going to
say about about charity or i'm in
chastity rather and so you know the
notion here is that this helps to
prepare us for being part of a divine
commonwealth
and you know he goes on and he uses some
examples here about adam and
christ as well but
what's important here is that fasting
helps to keep the body or the flesh in
check because it has a tendency to get
out of whack for desires to be too
strong or to open the door as he says
you know to demons right and so it's
supposed to strengthen us not so much in
our body but in our heart the
metaphorical heart that is the core of
the human being or
in the soul and he says something really
really important here as well if you
want your fasting to be good to actually
do anything to not be like the fasting
that the demons are capable of
you need not just to abstain from food
but from bad deeds from doing bad things
fasting by itself just simply
withholding food from oneself is not
intrinsically good
it becomes good within a
context and then it can have
its uh function made he says those who
abstain from food and do evilly imitate
demons for whom there's no carnal food
and spiritual wickedness is always
inside
it's better to renew the mind going to
conquer in perpetuity with the food of
holy preaching and the food of the word
of god than to satiate the belly of
death bringing flesh with earthly bread
and delicious
dishes
delicious dishes is how the chapter ends
right and then we have almsgiving in the
next chapter
and this actually comes from the greek
word
for
pity
or
mercy
like you know during the um
[Music]
uh liturgy when there's you know um this
you know have mercy on us lord that word
is actually being
invoked there so almsgiving is not just
like throwing money around because you
want to be a big shot that would be
actually vainglorious it's not just um
you know some sort of requirement
of justice it's going beyond that
but it does have a connection with
justice it's a way in which a human
being can be part of something bigger
than themselves and he sums it up by
calling it
providing for the wants of others from
the abundance
not just the abundance that you have but
the abundance that god
has given
so he says there's there's very many who
have no share in fields
none in vineyards none of the riches of
the world
whose wants we ought to provide for
so that they also with us may bless the
lord for the fecundity of the earth and
rejoice at their gifts from those
possessing things which have also been
made common to the poor
and to pilgrims
now there's a lot of interesting stuff
there so the poor those who
don't have
the resources that others do
but also pilgrims those who are
traveling
and need to be
helped out we might think of refugees as
being in both
cases right and so what does this
actually do
like he says um this allows them to
bless the lord for the fecundity of the
earth the fruitfulness of the earth
because people are
sharing that fruitfulness with them
rather than saying go get a job you know
or withholding it or saying get out of
here we don't like you in our
neighborhood so that's that's very
important
and
he tells us in a number of different
ways here that
there's a kind of recompense that is
being promised you know so you should be
good to those in this world not just so
they'll pay you back in this world but
so that um you'll be recompensed in the
next world as a matter of fact there's a
beautiful beautiful verse in there where
he talks about giving and you know what
you put in the purse of the poor man is
praying for you
right
that is is a wonderful way of thinking
about it what are you actually getting
though what
is it well you know you've got riches
here
don't heap them up heap up riches in
heaven is it like a whole bunch of
banknotes or gold bars or
houses or you know uh exercise machines
yachts whatever it's gonna be no he he
says that what you're actually going to
get is
mercy
mercy towards yourself right be merciful
and your mercy will be showing you and
forgiveness of your sins for the bad
stuff that you've actually managed to do
yourself right so by just distributing
alms
to um the poor you're actually
laying up something for yourself and he
says
don't fear expense
don't sigh about your doubtful yield
your substance when expended well is
augmented your rewarder
wants you to be generous so it's
participating in an economy
of generosity by
engaging in almsgiving towards the very
end he says there's actually three
different ways
in which we can give alms this is very
very interesting right so one is by
uh corporeal giving to another person it
could be giving them food it could be
giving them a ride somewhere where they
need it it could be burying the dead it
could be all these sorts of things that
we do that are sometimes called the
corporal works of mercy
but it can also be forgiving this is a
spiritual way of giving alms
those who need forgiveness from us and
who are actually asking for forgiveness
we can distribute alms by giving them
the forgiveness that they are asking us
for the third is he says to correct the
delinquent and lead the airing back into
the way of truth so
teaching correction
admonition exhortation
those might also be forms of almsgiving
now if you're kind of a self-righteous
jerk you probably should avoid that one
focus on the forgiving and the giving
aspects but you know for some people
particularly if they don't have an awful
lot of money
saying the right thing at the right time
to the person who needs it
could be quite good you know i'm
reminded of uh
uh antonin certians
when he uh
his response when asked who is my
neighbor and he says as you know
somebody who's intellectually
working it's whoever is in need of truth
and so that could be a form of alms
giving
uh the next chapter chapter 18 another
long one is about chastity and he's
going to say
unequivocally unequivocally this is very
interesting
chastity
is an angelic life he doesn't say
it's kind of like being an angel
it's it's being with the angels even
though you're not an angel he says this
is
an angelic wife
so he doesn't
cut any any corners there and he's you
know thinking perhaps about the life of
a
monk which is what he is
he says
those who live in chastity have an
angelic way of life on earth it joins a
person together with heaven makes them a
fellow citizen to the angels and then a
little bit later let no one say he is
not able to keep himself chaste for
faithful is god does not allow allow us
to be tempted beyond that which we are
not able to bear but will make provision
for the temptation so you know there's
there's a lot of temptations out there
now it's interesting too because what
does chastity include does it mean you
know just not having sex with anybody
that's the way a lot of people figure it
he says avoiding any sort of uncleanness
of body so you could you know easily be
unchaste even if you're not screwing
around with anybody
by indulging yourself
in getting a massage every day when you
don't actually need that massage right
it has to do
with the bodily
desires which include sexual desires but
also include a lot of other ones what uh
alko it includes under the capital vice
of lust is not just sexual actions he
also says
so it's avoiding uncleanness of body
especially unnatural ones right so
things that that really go against our
nature and that couldn't comprise from
his perspective a whole bunch of
different sexual acts but again could
include other things as well
you know if you think about what this
might encompass in terms of giving
pleasure or comfort to the body
and you know he says that
chastity is something that's necessary
to all most greatly to the ministers of
christ's altar that is priests monks
nuns
but
he also says that
there's scope for this within
sexual relationships he says you can
have a legitimate spouse
and that legitimate spouse
can be used legitimately now he's
actually talking about a man can have a
wife because he's writing as a monk a
male monk to
uh a male correspondent right the the
guy who he's writing this for but we
could easily
you know make this reciprocal and extend
it both ways it's possible for a
married couple from alchemin's point of
view to to have chastity it doesn't mean
virginity
it doesn't mean never having sex it
means using our desires and pleasures
and bodies
in the right way
so
these three
whatever we want to call them you know
actions
modes of virtue
help to guide a person away from the
three vices that we talked about
gluttony lust and greed
and towards a
better understanding and a better
relationship with their neighbor and
with god
you